well everyone's distracted with the
latest drama about masks and meat
shortages lots of strange stuff is going
on outside of the political spotlight
Obama era cover-ups Hollywood
environmental overhauls making it all
seem like this shutdown is more of a
shell game then the last half dozen
remaining never Trump errs on earth
conspire to take down the president and
in so doing they remind us why we got
rid of them all in the first place
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noah
[Music]
we'll get to Hollywood in just a moment
before that I would love your opinion on
who the most insufferable Hollywood
celebrity has been through this whole
pandemic or the least sufferable I guess
I don't know anyway your least favorite
celebrity let me know
we've got a whole lot to get to because
there's a lot happening that I think
we're all being distracted by other
things so that we cannot pay attention
to what's going on behind the scenes
we'll get to that in a moment first I
have got to thank our friends over at
the books company you know moms are
working way harder than usual this year
without a single day off so at the books
company that's short for bouquets makes
sense doesn't it they have decided to
celebrate Mother's Day all month long
put smiles on mom's face each month with
the flower subscription and get 30% off
plus free shipping now is the time to do
it
you get free shipping every time
subscriptions are flexible so you can
pause switch up delivery dates or even
recipients to cover all of your bases
you don't want long-term commitment well
try the gift trio for three months of
Farm Fresh balloons bucks absolutely
phenomenal right now to go check them
out I love these guys books calm slash
Knowles how do you spell that it's like
okay Bo you two s.com slash Knowles
place your order today if you'd rather
just buy one book you can still receive
25% off at checkout by entering the
promo code Knowles maybe you can't give
mom a hug right now but you can write in
her day at the books company go check it
out I really really recommend these guys
I always send flowers for Mother's Day
anyway they've got a tremendous product
and they've got a really great deal
running right now so check it out over
at bucks comm slash Knowles that's
number easy to remember never let a
crisis go to waste that's what the left
tells us that's what Rahm Emanuel tells
us that's what leftists have told us all
the way back to so Lewinsky and before
then why two reasons the two reasons are
one to seize on people's fear to ram
through policies that people would
otherwise object to that's the ID you
always want to have a crisis or take
advantage of a crisis or sometimes
encourage a crisis so that you can get
people whipped up and they're not
thinking as rationally and
they'll be more amenable to whatever
radical policies that you want to get
through and during times of crises
that's the time that radical policies do
get through so that's the first one
that's one we all know about there's a
second reason why the left and I guess
it's general political advice why they
never let a crisis go to waste the
second reason is because crises are
really really good at distracting people
from all the things that you don't want
them to see so it's not just about
getting people whipped up so they're all
paying attention to that you get your
policy through it's also about saying if
let's say there's a cover-up going on or
let's say there is some very complex
international relations happening over
here then you put a little puppet on
your hand and you say hey everybody look
over here nobody is looking at what you
don't want them to see and I think
that's exactly what's happening with one
of the running themes of the entire
Trump era from day one with President
Trump they have tried to throw this guy
out of office he was never supposed to
win right remember remember that it was
gonna be Hillary Clinton they said 99%
chance Hillary was gonna win 99.9%
chance and then what happened Donald
Trump won they immediately tried to
impeach him you heard in early 2017 Al
Green Democratic congressman said we've
got to impeach Trump not because he
committed a crime but because if they
didn't impeach Trump quote I fear he
will be re-elected so already they were
so worried about this then they try to
throw him out for Russia collusion
remember that then came out actually the
only people who colluded with the
Russians were the Democrats when they
compiled the steel dossier then it
turned out the Obama administration
spied on the Trump campaign then it
turned out things actually looked a
whole lot shadier in that investigation
than in the Trump campaign itself never
mind they tried to get Trump for not
paying his taxes and it turned out he
did pay his taxes then they tried to get
Trump for sleeping with a porn store
then they tried to get Trump for
colluding with Ukraine which is actually
a war with Russia kind of ironic I guess
he's playing both sides right none of
that worked and because there's a famous
political advice if you're gonna take a
shot at the King you better not miss
well they missed so now there are
investigations of all of their
wrongdoing and a lot of that is coming
out right now a part of that is over how
much Barack Obama knew about Joe
Biden's dealings with Ukraine I know
it's it's very complicated to keep all
of these moving parts in order but we
know we will remember this from the
impeachment this was part of the way the
impeachment backfired we know that Joe
Biden leveraged his power as the vice
president and the point person on
Ukraine
to fire a prosecutor in Ukraine the
prosecutor seemed to be investigating
his derelict son Hunter
Hunter was getting paid hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
for a no-show job on a Ukrainian Energy
Board Joe Biden was threatening to
withhold US aid if the prosecutor didn't
get fired looked very nefarious but
we're not allowed to hear anything about
that right so the Republicans are
investigating and investigating this
requires getting some documents from
Barack Obama Obama has just come out
himself and said he doesn't want to turn
over the documents I've got a letter
here was just obtained by BuzzFeed news
from the office of Barack and Michelle
Obama
this is to the archivist of the United
States and this this letter is being
written by Anita Breckinridge records
Representative to President Obama she
says President Obama has consistently
supported the nonpartisan administration
of presidential records at the
commitment and the commitment to
transparency core of nara's mission
however the current request is not a
proper use of the limited narrow
exceptions it arises out of efforts by
some actively supported by Russia to
shift the blame for Russian interference
in 2016 to Ukraine so they go right
right back to the script that got
disproven it was disproven by the Muller
report but they go right back to the
same script Russia Russia Russia
oh they're colluding with the Russians
that's why we can't show you all the
crooked activities we've been up to the
request for early release of
presidential records in order to give
credence to a Russian disinformation
campaign is without precedent then they
complain about that a little bit more
this use of the special access process
serves no legitimate purpose it does not
outweigh or justify infringing
confidentiality interests nevertheless
then she says they're willing to along
with it but they're trying to deal Ajith
amides us from the beginning why are
they willing to deal or why are they
fighting so hard rather not to let these
records out well Senator Rand Paul
thinks that he has the answer there's
been rumors for quite a while that
people within the Obama administration
knew about the corruption problems with
hunter Biden that they warned the vice
president and maybe even the president
about it I think that there could be a
smoking gun that there's actually a
record of some of these complaints that
were going on at the time there have
been some articles written quoting
unnamed sources saying that they were
assistants and people around and Joe
Biden at the time we're saying this
hunter Biden thing looks bad and you
should really put a stop to it and they
never did but I think even President
Obama knew about this so it's not
surprising to me that he would try to
keep a lid on it and not let any records
come to the public listen to that rumors
Obama knew Ryan Obama himself knew about
Joe Biden's shady dealings in the
Ukraine a lot of people have been
suggesting this for a while but no one
knew yet now it would appear that
there's possibly some documented
evidence of this might be a smoking gun
right Joe Biden basically admitted this
two days ago do you remember and that
cliff we played on this show two days
ago two or three days ago Joe Biden was
explaining why he doesn't want his own
documents opened up and he said don't
worry about Tara Reed it's not about the
personnel decisions but I had
conversations with the president about a
particular issue here's Joe Biden's own
words why not do it for both sets of
Records because the material in the
University of Delaware has no personnel
files that it has but it does have a lot
of confidential conversations that I had
with the president about a particular
issue that I had with the heads of state
of other places that that would not be
something that would be revealed while I
was in public office or while I was
seeking public office a particular issue
what's that particular issue right he's
not saying I had general conversations
is about a particular issue something
tells me that particular issue might
involve the terms burries m'a or ukraine
or hunter he had conversations with the
President and with heads of state I mean
Joe Biden you got to give him credit he
doesn't know how to keep his mouth shut
but we could have gotten basically the
same information from Rand Paul or from
Barack Obama himself this would be I
mean even with
the mainstream media totally covering
for the Democrats they they wouldn't be
able to help but cover this if we were
not in the midst of a pandemic and so
I'm not I'm not suggesting the reason
that we have a shutdown is to cover for
Obama but it is convenient and surely
political actors including allies of
Barack Obama are taking advantage of the
situation
speaking of the international sphere
though other weird stuff going on
scientists at the University of
Pittsburgh Medical Center who was
reportedly on the verge of making quote
very significant findings in the fight
against the corona virus was murdered
over the weekend inside his home
neighbors said the key and his wife kept
to himself a very quiet guy and yet he
was found murdered and the person who
they think murdered him then left and
killed himself in a car right down the
street
very odd now we know the the the doctor
by the way is dr. Bing Liu 37 he's from
China he was shot multiple times and
they believe he was shot by another man
how gu 46 who was lived in Pittsburgh he
may have been from China himself and he
got in his car 100 yards away and killed
himself I wonder what that's about I
guess it could be a coincidence
but it doesn't feel like a coincidence
it feels like maybe there's something
else going on here we know that China
has covered up this whole epidemic from
the very beginning the Chinese
government said initially it had no idea
what was happening
the Chinese government said initially
the virus has no connection to the
market Chinese government says
originally though the World Health
Organization says originally no don't
don't look over there now all of a
sudden as people are investigating this
all of a sudden people go dead people
turn up dead if we were not so concerned
about the masks and the craziness
surrounding that maybe we pay a little
bit more attention maybe this is giving
cover for some people who are who are
interfering international politics in
ways we couldn't possibly even speculate
on it's not just them though okay it's
not just this international sphere it's
not just Barack Obama course all the way
to the mainstream media goes all the way
to Hollywood there are big changes that
could possibly happen in this country
and they might happen without us even
knowing what hit us if we
pay closer attention we'll get to Chris
Cuomo in a second first though I've got
to thank our friends over at ring you
know safety now is more important than
ever I say but it's very hard to keep a
close eye on things right more
deliveries mean more boxes left
unattended more opportunities for
packages to go missing a lot of stuff
can happen out your front door and we're
not always free to check on things in
person with ring you can keep your home
safe no matter where you are so let's
say maybe you're an essential worker
you're at the office you're at work you
can check in very easily or if you're in
your home you can check in from the
front door obviously people are a little
on edge right now
so a very important time I love ring I
trust these guys I give ring to my
friends you can get a special offer on a
ring welcome kit right now when you go
to ring comm Noll scanner wles
the welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell 3-inch I'm Pro it's all you
need to start building custom security
for your home today go to ring.com slash
knowles ring.com slash no you by the way
i think i've given you this update on
the possum so I give this out to my
friend as a welcome gift right this is
before the shutdown before you had to be
worried about all these kinds of people
she thought a burglar was breaking and
it turned out to be a possum a little
possum had a possum baby a little possum
had a second possum baby that's the
lighter side of things or you can catch
a burglar before they break in either
way go check it out very important tool
to have so it's not just happening on
the international front it's not just
happening at the office of Barack Obama
those are two things that pay very close
attention to Chris Cuomo of CNN Andy
Cuomo's brother Fredo of the Cuomo
family he made his impassioned plea a
couple nights ago to the American people
to not lift the lockdowns this is his
people are sick of the lockdowns the
medical science was bogus the models
were dead wrong there's no evidence the
lockdowns are saving any lives or even
have saved any lives and Chris Cuomo
begs people in this very emotional weird
plea I want to just play you the last
few moments of this plea because I think
it's a bad harbinger of things to come
while we're all not paying attention we
know we can't do nothing forever but
think about what you are so anxious
to get back to in terms of normal and
what you're going to lose that we've
gained in this pandemic okay think about
it be careful what you wish for the time
with family the time together the time
leading more simply the time thinking
about where to go and where not those
pictures of what we see in Venice have
clearer water and clearer skies that
they're showing us all over the world I
know we can't do nothing forever but we
can think about how to be together
better I love how he starts it he says
we can't do nothing forever but it's
like yeah duh we can't do nothing
forever and yet he seems to make this
argument but you know we can do nothing
for a long time Lee says think about
what we will lose if we go back to work
I don't know our poverty and loneliness
I guess we'll lose that I'm fine losing
that what are we gonna we're not gonna
be able to watch CNN all day I actually
ironically I will have to watch more CNN
because I'll be going to the airport
more often he says careful what you wish
for it sounds like a threat to me and
then finally this weird line at the end
think how to be together better
I get so bizarre and it's it seems like
the guys on drugs or something it's so
such hippie dippie kind of talk but he
he is making a point he has a point and
a lot of people in all the areas that
the left has infected have been trying
to make this point what does it mean
think about how to be together better
what that really means is think about
how to improve our politics right that's
we are together politics is how people
can live together and get along together
how to do it better and I think there is
a major once in a lifetime once in a
century political shift that a left in
this country is pushing for through the
corona virus pandemic you even see it
you know forget New York and the CNN for
a moment go all the way out to
California governor Newsom has been one
of the true dictators true arbitrary
wielders of power and all of this
governor Newsom says okay we're gonna
reopen a little bit but not that much
and I'm gonna target my political
opponents in Orange County but by
rolling it open some businesses and then
he makes this broad political statement
about our progress and I think he's
talking about more than coronavirus
we're not going back to normal it's back
to a new normal with adaptations and
modifications until we get to immunity
until we get to a vaccine Yuba and
Sutter counties are allowing dine in at
restaurants hair salons are open and the
Yuba Sutter Mall plans to open tomorrow
you've said counties can go deeper into
face to a head of the state but can they
go into Phase three which includes
things like hair salons
if not then will these now open to
businesses need to close I said making a
big mistake they're putting their public
at risk they're putting our progress at
risk we've been clear about that well
aware of those examples these are
exceptions these are real exceptions the
overwhelming majority of Californians
are playing by the rules doing the right
thing we're not going back to normal he
says it's a new normal with adaptations
and modifications until we get to
immunity in a vaccine there's no vaccine
on the horizon do you think a vaccine is
gonna come in two weeks no no evidence
we'll get one in a year no evidence
we'll get it within two years no
evidence we'll get one at all sometimes
you just don't make a vaccine right till
we get a vaccine that's like saying
tomorrow tomorrow is always a day away
no going back to normal until we get
immunity it's a way for them to buy time
but they're saying we're in have a new
normal and the left always talks about a
new normal Obama that's all you heard
during the Obama administration this is
the new normal get used to it and the
American people said we don't like this
new normal we want to get rid of you and
go back to our old normal but that's
what the left ones new norms of living
he says they're the counties that are
opening up they're making a big mistake
they are putting their public at risk
they are putting our progress at risk
there is the key you hear that there I
guess he's directly talking about the
progress on coronavirus but I think
there's something bigger at play they're
putting our progress with a capital P at
risk these are exceptions the
overwhelming majority of Californians
are playing by the rules and doing the
right thing
meaning doing what I tell them to do a
threat of arrest or worse that's what
the left is always saying they're always
saying we're putting their progress
at risk anytime you elect a candidate
that they don't like they say oh you're
turning back the clock you're killing
people I mean they said we remember when
we all died from net neutrality repeal
that was in the million years ago it
seems like in the early part of the
Trump era I said if we repeal these net
neutrality regulations people will die
if we cut taxes a little bit people will
die it's going backward killing our
progress that's the exact same kind of
language they're using here except this
lockdown this unprecedented lockdown is
giving political cover from far more
monumental changes than net neutrality
repeal okay how do I know it again don't
you don't have to take my word for it
this is not some crazy kooky conspiracy
theory Hollywood leftists are telling us
this very thesis themselves there were a
bunch of Hollywood stars who just signed
a letter calling for basically a
complete overhaul of our entire society
not just our society but societies
around the world this is a true a list
of empty-headed hollywood leftists
Robert De Niro Madonna Cate Blanchett
Barbra Streisand Jane Fonda Juliette
Binoche Don who that is
ralph fiends Eva Green Adam driver
Penelope Cruz Willem Dafoe and Joaquin
Phoenix this is the letter that they
wrote this is more radical than the
Communist Manifesto some of this the
ongoing ecological catastrophe is a
medic Isis the massive extinction of
life on Earth is no longer in doubt is
that so are you sure sure I guess in the
long run we're all dead as John Maynard
Keynes said that but I I don't think
we're on the verge of an imminent mass
extinction of all life on Earth they go
on all indicators point to a direct
existential threat no just you you
people do and you don't know anything
you're talking about and even if the
scientists were pointing to that which
they're not the scientists are wrong
about everything the fact that they're
not pointing to a mass extinction
actually has me more worried that there
will be a mass extinction because did I
mention the scientists are always wrong
they go on unlike a pandemic however
severe a global ecological collapse will
have immeasurable consequences we
therefore solemnly call upon leaders and
all of us as citizens to leave behind
the unsustainable logic that still
prevails and to undertake a profound
overhaul of our goals values and
for these reasons along with increasing
social inequalities we believe it is
unthinkable to go back to normal the
exact same language that Gavin Newsom is
using the exact same sort of language
that we're hearing from everyone on the
Left we're hearing from Chris Cuomo this
is pretty big and it's two things are
happening at once the thing that you're
not seeing is all the cover-ups of all
the past leftist indiscretions of all
the thing I mean forget for a moment
China obviously trying to cover up their
guilt in the pandemic even the Obama
former Obama guys trying to cover up
their spying on the Trump campaign
trying to cover up everything they did
with Joe Biden and burries Minh Ukraine
everything they very likely knew about
all right there they're using this
massive transformational event as cover
so that no one remembers what they did
don't forget the left is always
rewriting history but then at the same
time what they're beginning to let us in
on is the evidence that they are calling
for a massive fundamental transformation
Joe Biden use that phrase Barack Obama
uses that very phrase fundamental
transformation do you want a fundamental
transformation I I don't think I do what
does this all mean does this mean that
the coronavirus is all a hoax cooked up
by Bill Gates and the Illuminati no I
don't think so I don't think so what do
I know I'm not a member of the
Illuminati they didn't let me in but I
don't think that I don't think you have
to believe that this endemic and this
shut down are all some grand conspiracy
cooked up by people in a room I think
what we all have to admit though is that
leftists are taking advantage of this
whoever is it well I mean China's at
fault but even forget all the steps in
the first place the left is very clearly
taking advantage of this their steps
have not proven effective to slowing the
virus or saving lives but they are
proving increasingly effective at
pushing the same kind of
transformational change they've wanted
for a hundred years and I I think we're
talking about something much bigger than
a pandemic here right we're talking
about a religious shift the religion is
environmentalism the scientists are the
high priests the media stars of the
evangelists here that is the kind of
framework that all of this is in but it
would change the economy it would change
the way we live it would change the way
that we get around it would change the
way we have air travel it would change
everything we're seeing what it feels
like to have those things changed right
now and the left is pushing ahead and
saying this could be the new normal
don't give it up what are you rushing
back to we can't go back let's stay in
this isolated misery forever that's not
the life that I want but that's a clear
choice and we happen to be in an
election year we will get to a little
bit more in just one moment first I've
got to thank our friends over at which
friends do I get to thank Rock Auto I
love Rock Auto Rock Auto makes shopping
for car parts so easy with the
increasing number of makes right Fiat
IKEA different models the Pacifica the
xt5 the a B C D I don't know the model
names it's now impossible to stock all
the parts that you need in a traditional
chain storefront why endure the often
pointless and seemingly intimidating
questioning why wait well wait while the
guy at the counter just goes online
probably to Rock Auto orders the part
and then just charges you twice as much
doesn't make any sense at all chain
stores have different price tiers for
the professional mechanics and the
do-it-yourselfers rockauto.com does not
thing I love about Rock Auto family-run
it's been around for a long time for
basically as long as the Internet's been
around it has every part you need and
even for me someone who is completely
ignorant when it comes to these kind of
questions about cars I don't know a
single thing about cars or trucks even I
can navigate their catalogue go right
now it's family business amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need you can go
to Rock Auto calm and the most important
thing by the way is when you go to
rockauto.com and you see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Knowles K no W le s and there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you so as the left is
trying to radically change our politics
they're gaslighting us on it okay we saw
this we see this with the mask order CNN
is kind of let it letting the masks slip
a little bit actually pun very much
intended they came out with an article
yesterday called the psychology be
kind why some people won't wear masks
look at that words psychology it's not
why people won't wear masks it's not the
rational reasons why people have
political disagreements it's not the
reason why some people are interpreting
the scientific evidence to realize that
there's not a huge threat when you're at
an wide-open space and you're a young
person and you don't have other
comorbidities right uh-huh it's the
psychology behind why some people don't
this this goes back to what liberals
were saying in the middle of the 20th
century about conservatives they said
that conservatism was just a series of
irritable mental gestures that sought to
give the impression of real thought it
was just irritable mental gestures and
that's what they're saying here CNN is
interviewing a bunch of doctors a bunch
of physicians to tell us when we can
reopen they're interviewing a bunch of
psychologists to try to explain why
people have different political points
of view as though people don't have
their own faculties of reason as if if
you voted for anybody who's not a
leftist if you in any way disagree with
leftist policies then you've got to have
something wrong with your psychology
never mind by the way that the left was
telling us these very doctors were
telling us three weeks ago not to wear
masks the Surgeon General three
exclamation points don't wear masks then
two seconds later they say you have to
wear masks forget that that would be my
maybe well part of my reason why I don't
think I need to wear a mask all the time
but no it's the psychology something's
got to be wrong in your head this can
all be explained by the dictatorship of
science history politics it's all a
matter of science put the guys and the
white lab coats in charge they all
coincidentally happen to be leftists and
then let them run your lives for you
very pathetic and some people who don't
get the stakes here are the five
remaining never Trump errs in America
yeah there are that many there used to
be a lot of never Trump errs now there
are like two people left in a basement
somewhere they've come out with an ad
called morning in America and it just
shows they don't get what's going on
there's morning in America
today more than 60,000 Americans have
died from a deadly virus Donald Trump
ignored with the economy in shambles
more than 26 million Americans are out
of work the worst economy in decades
Trump bailed out Wall Street but not
Main Street this afternoon
millions of Americans will apply for
unemployment and with their savings run
out many are giving up hope
millions worried that a loved one won't
survive kovat 19 there's mourning in
America and under the leadership of
Donald Trump our country's weaker and
sicker and poorer and now Americans are
asking if we have another four years
like this will there even be an America
paid for by the Lincoln project which is
responsible for the content of this
advertising morning in America you get
it mo you are and ing
you get it it's really it's really
clever huh because it's like them in the
1980s and 84 Reagan had an ad called
morning in America with the sun shining
and they're doing morning in America you
get it you get it it's a pun never mind
that how offensive this ad is and the
idea of the upside-down American flag
really that's an inappropriate use of
that image not that these guys know
anything about what's appropriate or
reverent but it's also just so lame what
a lame ad I mean its first of all it's
made for TV which has been dead for 10
years now
second of all it's this stale imagery
and the and the deep booming voice on
the voice over Donald Trump is bad
that's right this ad paid for by people
against Donald Trump he's bad it's just
like so lame make a meme or something
man you know this is 2020 already it
shows us that obviously they don't get
it the this group of people are all well
president Trump can tell you himself
he his words not mine they're a bunch of
losers I saw a project they they called
the Lincoln project and I would have
them change the name to the loser's
project because if you take a look at
[ __ ] it's this George Conway the guy is
Kellyanne must have done a big number or
George Conway and some other people
Weaver every one of them I either
defeated or they lost by themselves but
it's a group of major losses they're
Republican losers and if they would
really think about it
I have 252 beautiful brand-new
conservative wonderful judges two
Supreme Court judges that are great we
produced the greatest economy in history
until a month and a half ago well we got
hit by the virus so we had to close it
down and we'll do it again we've rebuilt
our military we've done things that
nobody has been able to do I've gotten
the greatest tax cuts in history in the
history of our country the biggest tax
cuts the Democrats were to raise in
taxes I've got regulation cuts the
biggest in the history of our country no
matter how long a president serve with
all of that I guess they don't like me
but let me just tell you these are
losers from day one yes so you know
President Trump doesn't mince words here
they have lost a lot of campaigns I mean
they lost campaigns for John McCain for
John Kasich for Mitt Romney for the
right they just they're not the varsity
squad when it comes to political
consultants so they've missed the time
they've missed the shift they're also
missing what's happening in politics
right now and that is my big fear I fear
that people are missing what's going on
I think I think a lot of people are
waking up the ones who understood what
the Trump election meant even if you
don't love Trump even if you don't like
the way he talks what it meant that you
had this guy who had kind of different
policy prescriptions who kind of talked
a little differently acted a little
differently vanquished the house of
Clinton shook things up the fact that
that guy won really meant something that
we've moved into a new kind of politics
or we're moving in that direction now
there is a fundamental transformation
that is underway or that the left wants
there to be underway and we can either
go along with it wake up one day and
realize we lost our whole country and
our whole culture or we can push back I
as you might have noticed suggest the
latter all right we got to get to the
mailbag first though I have got to thank
our friends over at oh yeah that's right
you I've got to thank you and I want to
tell you about daily wires newest
most exclusive membership tear the
all-access insider the all-access
insider Membership dear is our premium
level of membership this is like the
jewel encrusted diamond encrusted
leftist tears tumbler goblet of members
year level membership levels the
all-access members get the benefits of
our other membership tiers including an
ADD free website experience access to
all of our live broadcasts and shell
library access to the shows mail bags
and the three full hours of the Ben
Shapiro show all along with dedicated
editorials from ben shapiro then you get
the Q&A is in the discussion and you get
the all-access show where we get to
interact and you get the irreplaceable
leftist here's tumbler i am going to be
joining you on the all-access show
tonight that'll be at 8 p.m. Eastern
5:00 p.m. Pacific I call it this show
it's not even really a show it's just
kind of hanging out so be there be there
be square Ben will be doing it tomorrow
so go check that out daily wire.com
slash subscribe to join daily wires
all-access Club with a new membership or
with an upgrade and you will get 10% off
with coupon code Knowles it's my gift to
you the only wire that comes last
subscribe we'll be right back with the
mailbag
all right let's get to some mailbag
first question from Andrew hey Michael
has feminism been beneficial for society
even first wave feminism you anticipated
that I would say no so you followed up
for the question in your question even
first wave feminism good thinking if not
has it been the primary cause of
deteriorating the nuclear family and
women themselves Thanks love your show
and all that you do
feminism has been very bad it's been bad
for women primarily it's been bad for
men it's been bad for children it's been
bad for society it's been bad for
everybody now you asked about first wave
feminism and this is a clever trick that
feminism plays I guess where they divide
it up into waves you never know quite
what wave you're in are we in the fourth
wave or the third wave or I don't know
it's all kind of the same problem you
know the third wave that's when you
start to think of like the blue haired
women who are screeching and you know
who are redefining gender and but
actually some of them don't want to
redefine gender it's very very very
complicated whereas when you think of
the first wave if you think of the
suffragettes or something like that
that's obviously much more respectable
and sort of normal than the blue haired
bra burners but the problem is feminism
itself and you know I you could refer to
social scientific data here that show
that women have become less happy in
both relative terms to men and absolute
terms for every year that feminism has
gained steam you could point to all that
kind of anecdotal data but the real
problem is philosophical feminism
misunderstands human nature it
misunderstands humanity itself one thing
that feminists and liberals try to do is
they say hey buddy do you know what
feminism means it just means that you
want equal rights for women
you just think women are end so if you
object to that you're a jerk and if you
agree with that then you're a feminist I
don't think so our civilization
Christian civilization has believed in
the spiritual equality of women from the
beginning goes back even before
Christian civilization goes back to the
Old Testament goes back to the very
first chapters of Genesis where II
is pulled from Adam's rib this image is
very important if Eve were pulled from
Adams head then Eve would be above Adam
if Eve were pulled from Adam's foot she
would be below Adam but Eve is pulled
from the rib right there smack-dab in
the middle representing a spiritual
equality so of course men and women are
spiritually equal but equal also has
this connotation especially these days
of being the same and men and women are
not the same which you would know if
you've ever talked to a man or a woman
but very different men and women
complement each other and they have
obviously physically are different
temper mentally often they're different
so what feminism tries to do is take
this equality which as we've always
believed in and turn it from a
complimentary equality into an identical
equality the men are exactly the same as
women and and that's obviously not true
that's made women miserable it's made
society coarser it's denied the
fundamental nature of men it also buys
into a lot of other kind of liberal
premises that we don't have time to get
into now but it's just wrong and so when
you say are you a feminist or you're not
a feminist is feminism good as feminism
bad it's just wrong it's incorrect in
what it says about men and women in
human nature and so it's probably not
not a very useful thing to use to guide
society from Alex hi Michael
I heard you mentioned that you were
brought to the Catholic faith by way of
Protestantism can you describe what in
particular convinced you that the
Protestant view of Scripture was
insufficient or errant in that
conversion I draw I feel a draw toward
Catholicism which from what I can tell
comes from a desire for shared community
with them that I'm missing out on
however the Catholic view of Scripture
has some worrisome points for me
specifically the ongoing sacrificed of
Christ Christ presented in the
sacraments as opposed to final
justification on the cross what are your
thoughts on this well I can a suede
other like seven questions in there I'll
try to run through them quickly I can a
sways your fears about this idea of the
continual ongoing sacrifice of Christ in
the mass the mass is a is a memorial
sacrifice right it's the highest form of
prayer but that doesn't mean that Christ
is being crucified every single mass as
though Christ's crucifixion was not
sufficient Christ's crucifixion was a
one-time event that was sufficient for
salvation now the memorial sacrifice of
the mass is
right the Eucharist the real presence of
Christ all of that is true
a sacrifice does not always need to
involve a killing right you see in Hosea
you see in the Psalms sacrifices of
rejoicing sacrifices of Prayer right it
doesn't always have to involve like
killing something so that's a little
entrant to discuss what the mass means
and the Eucharist means it would take a
very long time
but that's a little introduction you
could find more at a resource called
Catholic Answers perhaps that that if
you google around there I think you'll
get some more answers on that just ways
your worries in terms of how I came to
Catholicism from prata through
Protestantism it was a Protestant my
good friend who make a church Protestant
who kind of brought me over and
convinced me that God exists in the
first place now the end of this story
though by the way is that that pal of
mine is joining the Catholic Church so
he kind of went the same way that I did
I suppose there were a few things here
one I believe that Christ gives Peter
the keys to the kingdom of heaven and
whatever you bind on earth whatever
Peter binds on earth will be bound in
heaven whatever he loses on earth will
be loosed in heaven I think Peter is
Peter the rock on which Christ builds
the church I think he breathes on Peter
and the Apostles and they're their
followers or rather their successors and
they received the Holy Spirit and they
have the power to forgive sins and whose
sins they forgive her forgiven and whose
sins they retain and retained you see
the institution of confession of the
sacrament of reconciliation you see the
institution of the Eucharist and in the
Last Supper you see all of these things
there then there's the historical claim
we can trace the Pope's all the way back
to Peter and then to Linus and then all
the way up to Francis there is an
historical continuity here and then
there is this fact that you do have to
grapple with this if you're attracted to
Protestantism as I was which is why
there was basically one church for 1500
years I guess the Eastern Church split
off but not in the same way you know I
think of that as sort of like the two
lungs of Christianity the Protestant
revolution was a much firmer break and
so you've got to ask why everyone
basically agreed for 1,500 years and
then why everyone split off from there
and in particular you have to ask why
the view
of Martin Luther and John Calvin and
Zwingli and the you know the the
Protestant reformers on on very what you
would call Catholic issues like the
perpetual virginity of Mary for instance
things like that the real presence of
Christ in the Eucharist why they were
though their views are so much more
similar to Catholic views today than to
the views of their suppose in the
Protestant denominations and of course
where Authority ultimately comes from
and why there are thirty thousand
Protestant denominations and which one
is right and who you can refer to and
maybe what the advance of the all those
various denominations has to do with the
rise of our modern era I gave you about
ten answers there I don't know if any of
them got to it in particular but those
are some of the reasons that led me
ultimately to the Catholic Church and
probably I wouldn't have gotten there if
not for the Protestant churches too so
that's a good thing but you know one has
to keep thinking about these issues from
Joshua what are your thoughts on
eliminating the payroll taxes for the
remainder of the year in lieu of
continued payments to the American
people
yeah cancel them forever that like
forget their end of the year like get
rid of them that works for me
from David hey Michael I'm doing a
research on homelessness in the US and
the best way to fix it unfortunately the
vast majority of what I can find
especially from Houston where I live is
that government provided affordable
housing is the answer to all of our
problems hmm about that and how houston
is evidence of that what are your
thoughts especially living in LA which
is just one big homeless camp at this
point and can you point me to any good
research on the subject what actions
could local government take to prevent
or stop homelessness thank you so much
so getting back to Christianity the poor
will always be with you you're not going
to cure homelessness ever okay that's
not possible it's a utopian liberal pipe
dream that's not going to happen you can
reduce it a little bit you can deal with
it more effectively but I don't think
just giving everybody a bunch of free
houses is the way to do that
I think when you look at who is on the
street disproportionately overwhelmingly
you're talking about drug addicts and
the mentally ill or who have been left
behind by society those people have been
left behind one because we don't enforce
our laws strictly enough to because we
closed down the mental asylums and we
made it virtually impossible to commit
somebody to an asylum against their will
and the reason for that was we had the
development of a lot of psychiatric
drugs that could help people and so they
wouldn't have to stay in the asylums
anymore trouble is once they got out of
the asylum they stopped taking the drugs
and so all of a sudden you're right back
at square one we should make it easier
to commit people we should rebuild some
of those asylums would be much better
for people to be getting treatment there
than living on the street we should make
it easier to force people into drug
rehab and we should arrest people who
are criminals because there is no right
to living on public lands on the street
it's not good for anybody harms the
individuals or do it in armed society
from Nick how much you selling the
painting of the moped for thanks so one
of my hobbies that I've developed during
quarantine is that I've taken up
painting I consider myself a modern-day
Caravaggio if Caravaggio were like a
finger painter and so I have made a few
masterpieces obviously and I guess the
only thing I can say to you is what do
you want to pay let's start the bidding
let me know from Danny dear Michael if
Joe Biden dies before the election who
becomes the nominee that's morbid not
implausible but morbid also if the
Democratic Party decides they no longer
want to back Biden can someone else
receive the nomination during the DNC
who do you think that might be Thanks
yeah so if that's kind of a sad thing to
contemplate I love Joe Biden I hope that
he's always the Democratic nominee for
president and I think the Republican
administrations will last for 2,000
years Joe Biden if he were not able to
be the nominee then that would open up
the convention you know Bernie Sanders
still has a lot of Delegates so the
delegates that Joe Biden it don't forget
they haven't actually nominated Joe
Biden yet so the delegates that that Joe
Biden has they would go to somebody else
you'd see a floor fight Bernie Sanders
and make a strong claim to it because
they robbed him in 2016 and he got
pretty far this time too if the party
decides they want to throw Biden out
they can do that you know they say they
can't but look they're cancelling all of
these primaries are postponing them talk
about never let a crisis go to waste
talk about keeping everyone distracted
well a lot of weird stuffs going on
behind the scenes what happened to these
primaries what's going on with these
delegates they're postponing now the
Democratic National Convention
it could be anybody's game and if you
saw a candidate like Michelle Obama or
somebody else jump in there or even her
dreadfulness Hillary Clinton I wouldn't
be totally surprised because Biden just
doesn't really seem to have it all right
one last question from Marcus dirac offa
I like that that's it's one of my older
nicknames I need your help understanding
how all these states and local
governments are getting away with
violating our rights I look at the
Fourteenth Amendment and it says no
State shall deprive any person of life
liberty and property I hear you talk
about this too on your shows yet nothing
is being done how can the states take
our lame governor Newsom as an example
tell business owners they cannot be open
isn't that depriving them of Liberty yes
and no the states have police power
during pandemics three times of war they
always have this was not thought to be
unconstitutional though if you took a
very narrow reading I suppose maybe it
could be the broader lesson here is we
are not governed by the Constitution put
that fiction away with the Tooth Fairy
and Santa Claus and the Easter Bunny we
are not governed by a piece of paper to
quote Antonin Scalia there is not a
living Constitution the Constitution is
dead and it's not only dead in the
textual sense it is dead in so much as
the way that it governs us is through
the institutions that it established
Scalia would talk about this all the
time say stop reading the Bill of Rights
Bill of Rights doesn't do anything for
you the Constitution sets up
institutions which protect your rights
but the piece of paper itself does not
and the real lived Constitution that we
are governed by is very different than
the one that's on the parchment paper
I wish we were governed by the parchment
paper but no society ever has been
governed by a sheet of paper it's always
enacted and fleshed you know
institutionalized in these in these
institutions that govern us and the left
has infected those institutions and
turned them against maybe the purpose
purposes for which they were set up
there's a big power grab going on right
now it's very important that in subtle
maybe even slightly humorous acts of
defiance we tell them that we're not
going to take it that's our show I'm
Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Dahl show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there